a satanic temple has set up a display
inside the Iowa State house there was a
uh satanic altar placed in the Iowa
state capital uh let's show you the
image here the image uh is from Jack pic
that is a satanic altar okay and that is
the state capital and what Jack wrote
there and I've had Jack on the show
several times uh but this is going to be
a sort of similar theme to what we just
discussed with Dana White uh Jack wrote
this is what Kim Reynolds has allowed to
be installed in the Iowa state capital
it is a satanic alter and Idol now it is
a satanic alter and Idol uh but it has
nothing to do with Kim Reynolds and and
there's a reason that poic is going
after Kim Reynolds I'll explain that in
a second it was Community noted which is
the factchecking apparatus of Twitter as
you guys know the Iowa capital is
controlled by the Iowa legislature not
Governor reyolds the department of
administrative Services manages access
for displays at the capital which are
open to any one through an application
process and do not discriminate on the
basis of religion or ideology now there
is an absolute conversation to be had
about these types of satanic things
being put on public property right and
I'm I'm actually more on the side of
that they should not be there let's just
put that aside for just a second okay uh
it had nothing to do with Kim Reynolds
as the factchecking pointed out but
pesobic who is in Trump land wants to
hit Kim Reynolds because Kim Reynolds is
backing the santis right so it has
nothing to do with Kim Reynolds but
again this was really going after d
santis and actually you know who kind of
did the thing that caused it so that the
satanists could have their things in the
yeah it was trumped here's Des santis
last night he did a town hall on CNN
with Jake Tapper so it's interesting I I
I heard this and then I was like well
how did it get there is that even a
religion and lo and behold the Trump
Administration gave gave them approval
to be under the IRS as a religion so
that gave them the legal ability to
potentially do it so I don't know what
the legislature what they how they
analyzed it but it very well may be
because of that ruling under Donald
Trump that they may have had a legal leg
to stand up my view would be that's
that's not a religion that the founding
fathers were trying to create um but I
do think that IRS ruling uh I was really
surprised to see that they did that okay
all right so there's a sort of similar
theme here to the to the opening of the
show I'm not just trying to attack
people willy-nilly but sometimes we get
some wins on things and and when we get
wins on things we have to take those
wins but we also have to not make
everything so political that when a
satanic Monument shows up in the Iowa
state capital and you're like oh I can
get Kim Reynolds over that because the
guy I really want to get is des santis
and then of course it turns out that it
was the Trump IRS that made them you
know a quote unquote uh religious
organization to get that tax exemption
and that's why they are allowed there so
you have to call balls and Strikes even
when they're roughly on your same side
because that again is what will help us
beat the Real Enemy so the 10%
differences or whatever you want to
think those differences are those things
that's the space that we got to operate
in we got to kind of put those aside and
go for the Real Enemy but also
acknowledge let's not burn each other
down at the exact same
time